bonjour bienvenue à tous bienvenue dans
europe hebdo c'est parti pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans cette
émission je vous emmène à riga en
lettonie un pays qui compte une grande
minorité russophone particularité ils
sont en majeure partie apatrides c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont aucune nationalité
comment cette réalité peut perdurer en
europe
nous en débattrons avec mes invités mais
d'abord direction lesbos cette petite
île grecque vont affluer depuis des mois
des milliers de réfugiés sur ses côtés
chaque jour une situation explosive qui
conduit certains pays d'europe a
souhaité sortir la grèce de l'espace
schengen une polémique qui ne manque pas
de faire réagir politique et habitants
sur place reportage faustine saint
geniès
une mer agitée et des vents violents
la côte turque n'est qu'à quelques
kilomètres mais aucun migrant ne devrait
tenter la traversée aujourd'hui trop
dangereux pourtant c'est ici sur l'île
de lesbos que sont arrivés cinq cent
mille personnes l'année dernière
la moitié des réfugiés qui entre en
europe ici vous avez plus de 500 moteurs
et chaque jour on ne reçoit d'autres se
garde côtes réceptionne les rafiots à la
dérive dans les eaux territoriales
grecques jusqu'à 50 personnes
s'entassent sur des zodiac comme celui
ci ont parfois les réfugiés eux-mêmes
saborde les moteurs oui il ya des fils
électriques à équiper une fois les
migrants secourues ils sont conduits au
camp de moria le premier hotspot à
quelques kilomètres de mytilène la
capitale de lesbos ici ils sont
enregistrées dans les fichiers européen
par les employés de l'agencé frontex
mais depuis quelques mois ces
volontaires de médecins du monde
accueille de nouveaux profils de
migrants depuis juin on a vu arriver des
familles avec des gens de tous les âges
du nouveau-né de trois mois aux
vieillards de 105 ans ce jour là le camp
est presque vide
seuls les mineurs isolés et quelques
familles monoparentales sont hébergés
nous ne sommes pas autorisés à les
filmer pour les protéger des trafiquants
c'est lié au mauvais temps aux
négociations en cours en europe
mais dès qu'il fera meilleur il est très
probable que la déferlante reprennent de
plus belle
lesbos coeur de la crise migratoire
accueille le premier hobsbawm en europe
quatre autres doivent être
opérationnelles en grèce dans les
prochains jours seulement le contrôle de
l'identité reste insuffisant sur les
quelques 1200 arrivées quotidiennes
seuls 800 migrants seraient correctement
enregistrés la grèce de montrer qu'elle
fait de son mieux mais elle est dans le
collimateur de bruxelles qui menacent de
l'exclure de l'espace schengen inutile
et inefficace jugent le maire de
mytilène pour lui le problème ne vient
pas de la grèce nous avons
i que la clé est la solution se trouve
en turquie c'est là que ces personnes et
ces immigrés doivent être enregistrées
afin de mettre un terme à ce crime qui
se déroule sous nos yeux il faudrait
qu'il y ait une négociation avec les
turcs dans un premier temps et si les
négociations n'aboutissent pas il faudra
alors passer par la contrainte
en attendant les autorités grecques ont
accepté la semaine dernière le
déploiement des navires de l'otan dans
la mer egée pour endiguer l'afflux de
migrants
une première voilà de retour sur notre
plateau et pour débattre de cette
situation dramatique à lesbos est de
savoir s'il est utile ou pas d'exclure
la grèce de l'espace schengen je reçois
mes invités cécile ducourtieux bonjour
je vous êtes journaliste au monde et
spécialiste des questions européennes
vous êtes correspondante de ce journal
ici à bruxelles bienvenus en face de
vous jean arthuis bonjour vous êtes
député européen français président ici
de la commission des budgets du
parlement vous êtes ancien ministre du
budget en france et surtout ancien
sénateur et vous revenez d'un voyage que
vous avez effectués en turquie vous avez
pu visiter des camps de réfugiés syriens
vous nous raconterez merci à vous cécile
king et bonjour vous êtes députée
européenne italienne et vous êtes membre
du groupe socialiste et démocrate et
vous êtes anciennes listes de
l'intégration du gouvernement d'enrico
l'état vous aviez eu à gérer à l'époque
la crise à lampedusa
on s'en souvient et vous revenez vous
justement d'un voyage sur cette île de
lesbos alors cécile klainguer première
question diriez vous que la situation
que connaît l'île de lesbos est à peu
près similaire à celle que vous avez
eues à gérer à lampedusa
et est-ce que sortir la grèce de
l'espace schengen est une solution
bon je commence par la dernière puisque
c'est la question que tout le monde se
pose le fait de sortir la grèce de la
spa de l'espace schengen moi je trouve
que c'est pas une solution puisque j'ai
été là-bas je me suis rendu compte que
la situation est un peu comme celle
qu'on a vécu en italie bon il y a en
plus de ça la grèce a eu des problèmes
c'est à dire est en train de sortir
d'une grave crise économique et à la
faillite
zone euro s'en souvient exactement donc
ce sont des problèmes qui s'ajoute au
problème de la capacité gestionnaire est
ce que j'ai trouvé là-bas c'est il ya
carence d'infrastructures donc
premièrement la grèce est en train de
partir de zéro
on parle du 1er au 30 mai franchement si
on parle de hausse porte les gens ne
s'imaginent pas ce que c'est exactement
ça c'est rétention d'identification
c'est un espace ouvert puisque ce que
vous avez vu dans le documentaire ce
sont les camps des réfugiés qui sont
derrière le hotspot
danlos quote c'est un espace ouvert là
où les gens arrivent ils s'enregistrent
et il manque aussi une coordination
entre les différentes agences
européennes on a là dedans frontex on a
un réseau on à europol mais on n'a pas
encore eu rojas mais il manque une vraie
coordination donc il ya aussi le passage
des données doivent passer dans tremper
une agence à l'autre
donc c'est pas une solution sortir
l'agresseur de shanghai puisque c'est
une question gestionnaire mais c'est
aussi une question de pouvoir dire la
grèce seul ne peut pas gérer ce
phénomène alors justement jean arthuis
vous êtes d'accord la grèce seul ne peut
pas gérer ce phénomène sur deux non pas
l'europe et est dans une situation
intenable
on a supprimé les frontières intérieures
dans l'espace schengen mais on ne s'est
pas préoccupé des frontières extérieures
et ceux qui suscitent ces migrations
c'est quoi ce sont les actions qui ont
été menées à l'occasion des printemps
arabes en libye en syrie et d'actionner
donc de lait les oeufs rolland a une
part de responsabilité mais sont pas
allés jusqu'au bout de leur démarche
parce que l'europe n'existe pas en tant
que tel au plan diplomatique au plan
militaire
on a déstabilisé on a déstabilisé et on
a le pas mesuré les conséquences et on
reste sur des dispositions qui font que
le pays sur lequel les migrants arrivent
est responsable de 2 de ceux qui
demandent le statut de réfugié en
l'occurrence la grèce et l'italie
laissée à la charge de la grèce et de
l'italie le poids de l'accueil des
réfugiés est insupportable complètement
dans leur en grèce c'est probablement
plus d'un million de migrants
qui ont franchi illégalement la
frontière entre la turquie et la grèce
donc si on dit la grèce est en dehors de
l'espace schengen ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les migrants et qui
aujourd'hui se concentrent en turquie
vont se concentrer en grèce quelle va
être la situation en grèce
on va créer un centre de rétention à
cette solution est absolument c'est
vraiment une vision à très court terme
alors on prend les dispositions ont fait
des annonces mais ça ne suit pas on a dû
annoncer puisqu'on a un budget le budget
européen est un budget anachronique est
incapable d'assumer les conséquences des
situations exceptionnelles et des crises
qui surviennent et on le voit bien ici
alors on a annoncé des transfuges pour 1
milliard pour la syrie on a annoncé
trois milliards pour les réfugiés en
turquie
mais aujourd'hui sur ces annonces il n'y
a eu que 40 millions d'effectivement
déboursés en turquie donc que l'europe
se ressaisisse
on dit que frontex va prendre des
dispositions mais frontex aujourd'hui
est juste capable de faire des
statistiques des franchissements
illégaux des frontières frontex n'a pas
les moyens de contrôler les frontières
extérieures cécile ducourtieux on se
souvient de la photo du petit adam qui
avait ému toute l'europe au mois de
septembre dernier qu'on avait retrouvé
donc mort sur une plage
on s'attendait à ce qu'une prise de
conscience collective au niveau européen
et que des actions soient menées
est ce que les états finalement sont
dans une posture à une ne veulent
surtout pas régler cette question mais
aujourd'hui il ya que l'allemagne
la suède l'autriche dans une moindre
mesure qui la règle enfin qui tentent de
la régler a trois ou quatre pays les
autres soit 70 intéresse parce qu'ils
estiment qu'ils ne sont pas impactés par
par la crise soit ils ont carrément dit
depuis le début
la hongrie est une partie des des pays
de l'est et des balkans que refusait
carrément de d'accueillir des réfugiés
aux motifs ou alors oscillent en
acceptant il fallait qu'il soit chrétien
voilà aussi entendu ça donc donc là là
la chancelière allemande se retrouve
quasiment tout seul avec des solutions
sur la table qui sont pas forcément
satisfaisante
ou alors qu'ils ont été réfléchis à très
court terme avec pas suffisamment de
moyens et d'engagement des autres pays
européens et donc on a en cela tu as
monaco en a les hotspots qui sont
effectivement un bon moyen de trier
entre guillemets les migrants seulement
il faut du temps pour que ça se mette en
place il faut de l'argent il faut
effectivement des personnels qu'ils
soient formés
il y en a probablement pas eu
suffisamment pas vraiment d'argent
suffisamment vite les grecs n'ont pas
suffisamment n'ont pas demandé
suffisamment rapidement au reste de
leurs partenaires européens de l'aide on
à l'ars que localisation des réfugiés
qui est un système qui fonctionnerait
avec moins de réfugiés en fait qu'un si
ça me paraît là on est dépassé
finalement tellement dépassés c'est un
système qui traite du cas par cas là on
est avec des centaines de réfugiés par
jour voire des milliers ça peut pas
fonctionner et ça fonctionne d'autant
moins que la plupart des pays qui sont
censés jouer le jeune homme
et quand on entend que la grèce
potentiellement pourraient être exclues
l'espace schengen parce qu'elle est
incapable de gérer ces frontières
extérieures ce n'est pas une forme de
cynisme aussi de la part de ses
partenaires
complètement en fait et puis alors le
processus qui a été enclenché
ces dernières semaines
à l'encontre de la grèce est d'abord
stigmatisant pour la grèce puisque cela
met à l'index de l'europe alors que chez
team ans de par sa géographie son
histoire la grèce et assume ce que les
autres pays n'ont pas assumé c'est à
dire l'arrivée des migrants elle est en
fait de la turquie a pas de choix
la deuxième chose c'est que d'abord
juridiquement c'est pas possible de
sortir un pays de schengen cela n'aurait
pas de sens parce que de toutes les
façons les migrants et puis les passeurs
trouverait trouverez la solution est
tout le monde le sait remontera la
frontière voilà bien sûr on serait
remonté il dépasse rizières en italie
enfin voilà il ya évidemment pas de
moyen de voilà installés tarifs déjà fui
la grille pour la plupart donc quand on
est dans une urgence vitale
on lève les moyens alors la présence
d'artistes migrants nombreux ouais en
grèce n'est pas nouvelle
il y avait plus d'un million de migrants
sur le territoire grec et l'avènement la
montée en puissance de l'aube dorée en
grèce est liée à ces phénomènes
donc les européens sont très hypocrite
en des circonstances ils n'ont pas pris
la mesure des enjeux n'ont pas pris les
dispositions on veut confier des
missions à frontex mais qu'elle est
l'instance de gouvernement l'europe
n'est pas piloté politiquement alors
justement vous revenez d'un voyage en
turquie vous avez été dans le camp de
réfugiés de gaza table vous avez aussi
rencontré des officiels turcs
pour l'instant la solution c'est la
turquie doit empêcher les flux de
réfugiés d'arriver en europe
oui on a l'impression un petit peu que
c'est la solution miracle contre 3
milliards d'euros promis à la turquie
alors vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure
que ces trois milliards semble-t-il ne
sont pas budgétée ou tout du moins qu'il
n'y aurait que 40 millions qui sont
arrivés à bon port ça faisait ça va
venir mais pour l'instant mais il ya une
part de chantage de la part des surcoûts
vraiment être une solution
yahia il faut aider les turcs mais c'est
pas la solution la solution c'est le
rétablissement de la paix en syrie et
dans le moyen orient c'est ça la
solution et il serait temps que l'europe
ait une diplomatie commune ce qui n'est
pas le cas actuellement
donc ce que font les turcs et de qualité
j'ai visité un camp que tout à fait
remarquable et on aurait mauvaise grâce
ou en tant que français à apporter une
appréciation critique quand je vois ce
qui se passe à calais en france
donc les grecs assument leurs
responsabilités dans les camps avec
l'aide des organisations humanitaires
internationales
mais il faut bien savoir que sur dix
réfugiés en turquie des invités comme
disent les turcs
il y en a un dans les camps et 9 à
l'extérieur des gants il ya à peu près
deux millions cinq cent mille migrants
qui sont sur le territoire turc
250000 dans les camps et le vrai
problème c'est pour toutes ces
populations qui vivent en périphérie des
villes et des villages c'est la
scolarisation des enfants il ya plus de
sept cent mille enfants syriens en
turquie et sur les 700 mille trois cent
mille sont scolarisés ça veut dire que
400 milles sont privés d'école
c'est pour ça brison qu'aider les turcs
finalement naturellement alors le risque
est un risque d'une génération perdue
ouais doit-on les conséquences d'une
absence de formation et de scolarisation
et cécile king et manuel valls premier
ministre français a déclaré à munich le
week-end dernier donc en allemagne qu'il
fallait stopper le flux de migrants et
que l'europe n'était plus en capacité
d'en accueillir vous êtes d'accord avec
cette affirmation
c'est un peu difficile d'accès un peu
difficile vraiment d'être d'accord
puisque moi je viens d'un pays qui a su
gérer les flux d'immigration puisque
j'étais dans un gouvernement qui a
commencé avec le programme marenostrum
oui et non ça veut dire solidarité et
partage équitable des responsabilités
c'est ce que devrait faire l'europe
normalement et l'italie a fait ça on ne
pouvait pas voir mourir les gens dans la
mer méditerranée puisque le problème
c'est pas le fait que les gens sont en
train d'arriver
mais c'est le fait qu'on doit intervenir
sur les causes profondes c'est à dire il
faut intervenir sur les conflits comme
l'a dit mon collègue tout à l'heure il
faut intervenir sur investir sur
l'accueil par exemple des personnes je
suis parti aussi au liban j'étais au
liban visiter les camps des réfugiés il
ya le liban et à la jordanie et à la
libye par exemple
donc il ya toutes ces saisons de
conflits et les zones de crise sur
lequel il faut investir donc avec une
forte politique étrangère une fois de
conférence
non au développement et c'est pas le
fait que l'europe n'est pas capable
d'accueillir puisque je peux vous dire
que l'europe accueille 6 % sur des
réfugiés dans tout le monde mais le 4e
26 ans est accueilli dans les pays moins
industrialisée nous sommes un continent
de 500 millions d'habitants et je trouve
que si je dois confronté notre continent
par exemple au liban le liban à 25% des
refuges et et nous on arrive à 1% 2 %
peut-être moi ce qui m'inquiète
aujourd'hui et c'est ce qui se passe en
syrie
oui les russes sont en train d'accroître
la pression sur les populations qui
s'opposent au régime de bachar el-assad
ça veut dire qu'il ya probablement 8 à
10 millions de syriens en syriens qui
sont des populations déplacées
ceux qui fuient à la présentation en
train de se concentrer sur la frontière
turque
mais les turcs ont fermé la frontière et
donc il ya là un risque considérable
alors je pense que poutine doit essayer
de taquiner si j'ose dire et c'est peu
dire
les européens politique sans
contrepartie de chez chômage en ukraine
cécile ducourtieux pour terminer sur
cette question on voit bien en fait qu'
on est dans une forme de folie crise il
ya des questions diplomatiques il ya des
questions les hommages qui qu'ils soient
là et on voit que typiquement l'europe
est complètement démuni pour répondre à
court terme à cette question là est ce
que le risque comme certains le disent
en le murmure tout du moins en ce moment
il ya un risque d'implosion l'union
européenne là dessus je pense en tout
cas pour pour écouter les dirigeants
européens
et leurs inquiétudes voire leur angoisse
parfois leur panique d'ailleurs qui
aujourd'hui on vit quelque chose qu'on a
deux totalement inédit au niveau
européen multitude de crises qui s'auto
entretiennent ou certaines crises qui
naissent d'autres crises
donc on est dans une situation très
grave et je pense que ce qui est c'est
d'autant plus affligeant que comme comme
le disait madame la ministre
l'europe va peut-être capoter ou
imploser à cause de quoi un million de
millions et de micros c'est totalement
ridicule fin avec un peu de recul c'est
à la fois ridicule et lamentable d'en
arriver à une situation pareille ne pas
être capable de gérer collectivement
l'arrivée d'un million à 2 millions de
migrants voire 3 550 millions
d'habitants 550 millions effectivement
on s'aperçoit là on est confrontés à au
court termisme au manque de 2 comment
dire d'esprit collectif de nos
dirigeants européens et probablement au
manque de leadership revenir tout à fait
pour revenir aux propos du premier
ministre valls à munich munichois et la
semaine dernière alors d'abord le fait
qu'on puisse pas accueillir davantage de
réfugiés
bon effectivement il ya des difficultés
la france doit en accueillir trente
mille voilà il ya des populismes qui
monte un peu partout dans tous les pays
européens c'est une réalité politique
dont il fonde revoilà donc il faut
prendre conscience qu'il faut tenir
compte mais je suis pas sûr que le
publions publics refusent ces arrivées
de réfugiés refuse les aider on a vu
qu'il ya eu des landes solidarité il y
en a encore et grecs nous donne
d'ailleurs il ya eu un sondage qui
indique que 72 % des européens qui est
actuellement il ya là quelques joueurs
sont prêts en fait à accueillir pour le
coup à la fille par ailleurs je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut aider la
chancelière
même si les solutions c'est quand même
effectivement un petit peu isolé genre
très rapidement l'europe donne ici
l'image d'une impuissance way est
insupportable l'accueil des migrants le
droit d'asile 28 pays
28 déclinaisons différentes du droit
d'asile
dans certains pays ils vont pouvoir
travailler immédiatement dans d'autres
ils ne le pourront pas dans certains
pays ne seront payés quelques quelques
centaines d'euros par mois dans d'autres
ne seront payés au smic
l'hébergement varie d'un pays à l'autre
donc on voit bien que l'europe l'europe
reste encore
simulacre d'europe parce que les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement ont voulu
garder toutes leurs prérogatives
notamment en matière d'immigration
eh bien on va continuer sur un tout
autre sujet parce que j'aimerais avoir
votre avis là-dessus il ya une autre
crise aux portes de l'europe qui a
réveillé quelques sentiments un petit
peu nationaliste
on a été à riga en lettonie autour de
rigueur on compte plusieurs milliers des
centaines de milliers en fait de ce
qu'on appelle aujourd'hui les apatrides
1 c'est un débat qui déchire la france
depuis quelques quelques mois un statut
interdit normalement par les conventions
internationales mais il s'avère que ces
apatrides sont pour la plupart
russophone une cinquième colonne entre
guillemets une minorité qui fait peur au
gouvernement letton jérôme bonnard a été
à leur rencontre
reportage
riga capitale de la lettonie une ville
de contrastes où se côtoient les
vestiges de l'époque soviétique et les
nouveaux quartiers depuis l'indépendance
du pays en 1991
de nombreux russophone vivent toujours
en lettonie comme tatiana à 63 ans
c'est le grand jour pour elle elle va
peut-être devenir citoyenne layton ce
n'est pas vraiment bien d'être apatride
être citoyen signifie exister et moi
j'aime la lettonie
asseyez-vous alors voilà comment va se
dérouler la matinée les candidats vont
passer un test de langue de constitution
et d'histoire layton une épreuve
obligatoire pour changer de statut nous
n'avons pas été autorisés à filmer
l'examen deux heures plus tard tatiana a
le sourire
on a réussi ou a fêté ça en lettonie sur
deux millions d'habitants 12% sont
apatrides c'est russophone se sont
installé durant l'occupation soviétique
et ne sont jamais repartis depuis
l'indépendance une loi les oblige à
parler couramment le letton pour obtenir
la citoyenneté pour les autorités le
langage c'est la base d'une bonne
intégration les éléments clés de
l'intégration c'est le langage c
comprendre les principes de bases d'un
état où vous vivez
quelles sont les valeurs de cet état
voilà pourquoi les gens qui veulent
devenir citoyens doivent suivre cette
procédure de naturalisation
mais la langue c'est aussi l'une des
principales contraintes pour ces
russophone qui vivent en lettonie depuis
des décennies aussi ils ne peuvent ni
voter ni exercer certaines professions
comme juges avocats aux fonctionnaires
alors pour certains députés cela
s'apparente à de la discrimination quand
une partie non négligeable de la
population est exclu de la vie politique
d'un pays ce n'est pas de la démocratie
la majorité d'entre eux sont nés ici ils
ont passé leur vie ici ils paient leurs
impôts et non pas d'autres terres qu'ici
en lettonie dans ce petit pays d'europe
après l'occupation soviétique la
question de l'identité est primordial
pour les lettons pour sept députés la
loyauté vis-à-vis du pays d'accueil est
une condition sinequanone pour obtenir
le droit de vote
j'ai peur surtout si l'on regarde ce
qu'il s'est passé entre la russie et
l'ukraine
certes les apatrides ne peuvent pas
voter c'est un droit politique pour
lequel ils sont limités mais je crois
que compte tenu de notre lourde histoire
nous devions le faire
c'est un choix politique très important
ceux qui veulent devenir citoyens et
être loyaux le peuvent ils pourront
ainsi voter aux élections
l'exemple ukrainien a ravivé la peur
d'une nouvelle emprise russe en 2012 les
autorités ont bloqué un projet de
référendum pour régulariser en masse les
minorités russophones en 2011
75% des lettons ont dit non à un autre
référendum sur l'introduction de la
langue russe comme seconde langue
officielle
pour ce politologue ces craintes sont
légitimes
il faut dire que les apatrides ont
facilement les yeux rivés sur moscou ils
vivent ici mais vous savez ils regardent
la télévision russe
ils reçoivent les cinq chaînes les plus
populaires et souvent ces télévisions
sont anti lettonie ont-ils ouest anti
otan voilà dans quel environnement il
dit et cela a une grande influence sur
leur envie de devenir les tongs pas là
dit mir lui n'a pas voulu devenir les
tons ouvriers dans l'armée aujourd'hui
retraité il habite dans une banlieue
éloignée de riga un ancien quartier
militaire russe et si le drapeau letton
flotte devant la maison il y a aussi une
raison particulière
c'est comme ça ici la mairie nous
demande de mettre le drapeau quand on a
des visteurs alors quand vous avez des
invités spéciaux j'ai mis le drapeau
pour vous
vladimir et sa femme sont arrivés il y à
une quarantaine d'années il possède
aujourd'hui un passeport de non citoyens
cela leur permet de voyager vers la
russie sans visa mais pas en europe pour
eux peu importe leur vie est ici loin de
la société lettone j'ai de la nostalgie
de l'époque soviétique avant c'était
bien on était une grande région je pense
que c'est de la discrimination
les estoniens les lituaniens ils ont
tous donné la nationalité alors pour moi
c'est un principe je ne veux pas à
prendre le letton y passer des tests
mais je ne suis pas en colère je n'ai
rien contre les lettons c'est la
politique c'est contre les dirigeants
que je pense cela plus de vingt ans
après son indépendance
la lettonie n'a pas oublié ce demi
siècle d'occupation soviétique et même
s'ils sont plus de 143 milles à être
devenus les tons le statut des apatrides
et toujours aujourd'hui une source de
friction entre deux gars et moscou voilà
pour sa reportage de jérôme bonnard à
riga jean arthuis ça vous étonne d'avoir
des apatrides sur le sol européen
oui mais je comprends la situation en
lettonie et en estonie aussi parce qu'il
ya le poids de 50 années d'occupation
soviétique n'a pas envie de revoir
l'emprise russe finalement ce qui s'est
passé en ukraine en crimée dans le
donbass justifie cette prudence et je
note que la porte vers la citoyenneté
reste ouverte
maîtrise de la langue bonne connaissance
de la constitution
donc c'est une situation de transition
oui cécile kengué vous êtes d'accord
c'est une situation de transition
finalement pour se défaire de l'emprise
russe mieux vaut créer des apatrides
bah moi je crois que il faut considérer
tout ça dans le cadre des droits de
l'homme aussi oui quand j'étais au
gouvernement je me suis beaucoup battu
sur la citoyenneté et je retrouve les
mêmes qu'à en lettonie puisque je me
battais pour la plupart des gens en
italie qui n'avaient pas de cycle un thé
ou bien des gens qui y en as vous savez
il ya pas seulement là il y en a aussi
partout en europe
bien sûr tout avec
avec les roms puisque en italie sont là
mais n'ont pas de nationalité et ils
sont la plupart sont des apatrides
j'ai dû intervenir une fois le tribunal
pour libérer deux jeunes garçons qui
étaient détenus en prison et qui était
supposée rentrée devaient être expulsés
dans leur pays
mais quel pays on ne sait pas ils n'ont
pas italien ils ne sont pas ils
n'appartiennent à aucun pays
j'ai dû intervenir pour leur dire qu'il
devait sortir avoir un statut d'apatride
puisqu'il n'avait pas de nationalité et
je crois que c'est une question de
droits de l'homme il faudrait que la
question de la patte de la patrie puisse
disparaître il ya quand même il ya aussi
une campagne sur ça puisque ce serait de
l'europe travaille beaucoup sur ces
régions il sait c'est une question de
droits de l'homme
il faut reconnaître chaque personne du
moment où l'europe est un moment qu'on
ne reconnaît pas les personnes c'est la
porte
l'ouverture de la violation de droits de
l'homme ouais cécile ducourtieux on
entend finalement assez peu parlé mais
cette emprise russe en fait à l'aise de
l'europe fini par complètement pollué le
débat politique et on le voit bien avec
cette question des apatrides en lettonie
oui c'est une question difficile et
effectivement je pense qu'on peut pas ne
pas considérer
le risque géopolitique pour le
gouvernement letton oui quand on voit ce
qui se passe effectivement avec rennes
donc c'est pas satisfaisant du point de
vue des droits de l'homme mais d'un
autre côté il ya une propagande russe
qui est totalement organisée aujourd'hui
comme on le voit dans le reportage les
russophones regardent la télévision
russe
les lettons dont probablement pas les
moyens aussi de faire de la contre
propagande way avait demandé d'ailleurs
à bruxelles il ya eu quelques volontés
des lettons d'activer des moyens
européens pour faire de la
contre-propagande là on a estimé ici que
il y avait probablement un mélange des
genres un petit peu dangereux enfin pas
se lancer demain contre-propagande mai
mais voilà la situation est compliquée
elle est pas satisfaisante mais
difficile de porter un jugement
définitif et par ailleurs ce qui se
passe en lettonie illustre un petit peu
la difficulté qu'on a à 28 à se mettre
d'accord par exemple sur la question des
migrants c'est vrai que dans les pays
baltes la question des migrants ce n'est
pas la priorité assure un type à l'un
des études cc l'ukraine et la russie
et idem sur le positionnement avoir face
à la russie et à poutine bien il a
écouté
merci d'avoir participé à cette émission
merci à vous de nous avoir éclairé sur
ces questions c'est la fin mais vous
retrouverez ahmed tazir la semaine
prochaine ciao